keep things simple then might not be
easy okay he starts with D4 normally in
must draw situations or where a draw is
good enough Wesley starts with his King
spawn taking 90 of the time so
interesting decision uh maybe he's
gambling on the fact that Prague won't
be able to play anything too active uh
for example if we do see the nimzo
Indian if we do see the Queen's camper
declines the two most likely openings
right now from this position then yeah
it's hard to
um it's hard to get too active as black
okay the this variation however does
have a reputation of being the most
solid I've played it myself countless
times as white it's often when I'm happy
to just play with a small advantage or
happy to not take too much risk and uh
okay black castles will Wesley push a
pawn forward in the center
there we go this variation is known to
lead to several different Force draws
for white if black had pushed the Deep
pawn two squares so uh maybe not playing
Black's best move which would have led
to some forcing draw lines uh instead
he's invited Wesley to step forward
gaining even more space and I remember
when I first played this variation as
black many many years ago I was shocked
I was like how can white get an
advantage all the white pieces are
asleep but it is very dangerous actually
so prague's taking risks it looks like
predicted this opening Choice by Wesley
so and uh he's playing a provocative
variation yeah at least now all the
pieces remain on the board for a while
and there's an immediate question to the
E5 Pawn how is he going to defend it and
that's why Wesley develops the bishop
but Prague he's not surprised at all and
he jumps forward attacks the queen I'm
expecting the queen to move one square
to the center to the D2 Square yep the
White Queen has a few choices she's
likely to move I don't think you want to
trade off this Knight yet the White
Knight can capture this Black Knight
that's just entered the center but then
Black's Queen replaces it and Black's
Queen is even more powerful so um you
know you want to allow this Knight
exchange on your own terms as white I
remember studying this position a while
ago though and uh from the black side
and I thought yeah at least it's
complicated I Was preparing it I Was
preparing this for black against a lower
rated opponent and I thought yeah this
was a good chance to at least confuse
them set them kind of uh non
non-standard problems and maybe that's a
practice concluded as well he's going to
set Wesley a few uh questions along the
way if he does want to equalize and
you'll move on the boardwalker yeah and
this incidentally here's the move with
the best stats and white has won 29 of
the time 57 of the time it's a draw and
uh black wins 14 oh that's low that is
low so I have to hope he hits that 14
yeah yeah and the most popular move is
actually to for black to trade off
Knights there is a second alternative
which is equally popular which is to
play F6 oh no one has played this move
oh now we're in a novelty area and
Wesley is on his own wow a novelty only
on move 10 so now Wesley has to
find something normally when we see a
novelty this early it does mean that
maybe it's not necessarily the best move
usually all the best moves have been
explored at some point in chess history
at this early stage normally the most
powerful Novelties are a bit later on
when the game is already very
complicated
here what could be the downsides of
Black's moves why has the evaluation bar
declared itself so high in White's favor
already it looks very logical to me
you're supporting Black's night in the
center of the board with this pawn move
you're protecting you're just
maintaining uh the tension here could
the downside be that Black's other
Knight is actually going to get kicked
back I was gonna say I mean I don't
think you have a good answer to White
simply playing h2h3 yeah this Knight
doesn't have many Escape squares this
might be the one problem for Prague has
he mixed up his opening move order here
it's quite possible uh to have mixed
things up because it's such a kind of
difficult position it's something that
arises quite rarely and this night yeah
there's no real Square to go to no safe
square if you Retreat to this Square the
only safe one you're just gonna get
captured I mean you maybe you don't even
get taken because it's such a bad Square
anyway but worse comes to the worst
white could capture and look at Black's
pawns now ugly and the black king also a
bit open and why wouldn't you move the H
port on two squares
to protect the night
uh that's a good question uh so here the
important taking the night is a big
threat uh for example if you push
forward and protect
um one of the downsides is that you lose
material you lose a night worth three
points you only get one point in return
uh also look at the white Rook it's uh
opened up
towards the black king
so it does look a bit scary and Wesley
has indeed played that move
what will we see Prague do here because
yeah you can't give up your night I
don't think you can allow it to be
captured and the alternative is actually
just playing Knight takes night but
unfortunately this series of trade also
doesn't favor Black at all because after
Queen takes Queen you can simply capture
with the king and the point is after
Knight takes porn
looks like you're one of some material
but oh no you haven't my friend because
the Rook comes up one square attacks the
Knight and is trapped yep no man's land
to your trap Behind Enemy Lines and
you're easily rounded up by the
opponent's Army so once again in this
position you would be forced to retreat
to a really bad Square on the edge of
the board this time I'm not sure where
the white even captures you but at the
very least I think Wesley would be happy
to trade off and in this type of end
game for example if the king moose
either the White Knight gets into some
really juicy outposts or you have to
trade off this Knight and if we do a
quick count here level material bow ties
have ugly pawns white has double deaf
Thorns black has Double H ones but the
key thing is it's guiding the game
towards a draw and that's the maximum
Pratt can hope for uh if he enters this
variation
so yeah it's looking like desperate
times already for the teenager
it's uh taking risks pregnant and I in a
must wear in the situation because
Wesley so one game three and let's hear
what he said to Tonya after winning that
game Wesley so
Wesley you've taken a lead in your match
with this win but it was strange how
quickly it turned around what went wrong
yeah very happy certainly I think
well there were many interesting parts
of the game but I think he should have
forced the trade of Queens at some point
I I keeping the Queens on the board and
playing F3 weakening the king's
structure is very very risky so you
should have played like win NATO at some
point trade the queens and get maybe a
little better end game but I actually
offered the door at some point I think I
moved 23 I wasn't sure I haven't played
this tournament for so long I wasn't
sure if you guys have the 30 move no
draw offer rule
before move 30. yeah I couldn't remember
because I couldn't remember the rules
thinking but yeah I just you know I
haven't played in so long but I think
yeah Park should have traded the Queens
I mean
when he played F3
yeah after H5 and then maybe he should
take on e4 because after he after gf3
maybe White
can have an advantage but it's super
concrete and he can easily lose the game
in the game is King around the mating
attack
uh the last game you're gonna be with
the white pieces you've already taken a
lead in the match uh what's the approach
they're solid or
push with white
no I mean of course I apologize for not
knowing the rules but uh I mean I'm just
very pleased to to win you know win win
a game against anybody then take it a
game at a time all right good luck for
the last round thank you
I actually I I don't think I've heard of
that on the tour this season anyone
actually clicking the offer a draw
button they always if a draw it's always
like move repetition yeah I remember a
couple of drawers but that's normally
like move 70 or 80 where they just gave
up winning chances and offered the draw
but yeah it's a bit naughty Wesley
but it was nice to see Prague just
ignore that and play on and uh despite
the fact that now he's in a must win
situation Wesley knows he can't bail out
with the draw Prague won't allow him
yeah let's see if uh the chess guard
punishes Wesley because she rarely likes
it when they offer draws but uh it's
looking good for Wesley so far I must
admit she tends to punish everyone
except Wesley
she has she has a soft spot for him I'm
gonna I must admit I I did quite enjoy
his humor when he said what were you
gonna do in game four against Prague oh
for a draw move one yeah I agree that
was very funny I wonder if the officers
would punish them if they agree to a
draw how do you punish them if both
players agree too early do you just
force them to keep playing yes I guess
that's the only way you sit here and you
play because in over the broadcast they
have this punishment nowadays both
players get zero points but if it's a
head-to-head like knockout situation
both players getting zeros the both is
the same as both getting a draw yeah so
um yeah it's uh I guess one of those
situations we're grateful that we
haven't seen ourselves in too often this
season so much Fighting Chess this year
yeah it's all about the players right
you're fighting players and talking
about players and fighting players I do
have to share with you one picture from
moo who sends us their favorite picture
of their favorite chess player who's
your favorite chess player David
apart from media Ivanka and apart from
you and Simon I'll say uh kramnik
chronic and here we have Michael tal the
magician from Riga and uh that's Simon's
favorite player yes
he really was a magician you know his
games are incredible and here we have
the line that we analyzed and Rook has
given a check to the king king will
probably take a step maybe to defend its
Pawn Yeah I think you can step in a
different direction though I think you
can maybe even step to the left because
black snake will still be trapped there
we go the white king keeps its Knight
guarded if you step the other way at
least black would have maybe been able
to ruin your Pawn structure on both
sides of the board but uh yeah you step
this way and Black's night
I think you have to retreat I think if
you jump in take that white Pawn enough
to you're still Behind Enemy Lines still
no way back but okay he is the king of
counter-attack every time we see him
play he counter-attacks and uh he's
leaving his Knight on pre but now he's
going for white start to go Bishop
interesting decision because now if
white star Square Bishop commits maybe
then Black's Knight has more options
wow this is uh I mean it's so clever
this move would not even be on my radar
I must admit I just see an attack I want
to react I want to retreat but Prague
he's never ever backing down and that's
all due to his coach Ramesh forcing him
saying okay Never Back Down never
Retreat always find Alternatives yeah
and uh yeah whether it's good or not I
think this is a clever uh clever idea in
a must-win situation
have to risk I agree I mean I had
completely forgotten about the
counter-attack better of course I must
remember it is Prague you feel that this
is a result of the calculation training
that he's so Adept at simply
highlighting those options and then
choosing from them because often when
you're calculating you do get kind of
caught up in this black and white
thinking which is a night is attacked
and I must Retreat and instead there are
Shades of Gray and The Rook comes down I
mean how should white react to this
capture the night that's one alternative
another alternative step back with a
bishop yeah it's not easy suddenly
because I thought I'd found a clever
variation for white but it doesn't quite
work so in this position The Rook did
come into D4 just to highlight again
there's a double attack actually on this
Knight but uh he didn't make any false
assumptions he didn't assume he had to
retreat and uh correctly he's jumped in
hitting this loose piece always look for
unprotected pieces in your opponent's
camp and yeah if the bishop moves uh the
problem is the bishop has to guard this
Pawn otherwise the Black Knight Will
Retreat and take it if the bishop moves
then now Black's Knight can Retreat yes
it's about square but it's about to jump
to a nice Outpost and now the difference
is that White's Bishop cannot capture
this Knight anymore and uh yeah so
therefore retreating the bishop feels a
bit wrong maybe it's still fine for
white but this Knight is about to
re-centralize I think Prague will be
very happy with this development
um the move I thought was quite clever
was to retreat White's Knight you attack
the black Rook you defend your Bishop
what could be more natural you also
maintain the attack on Black Knight but
after Rook takes Pawn Check Yes the
black Rook is actually trapped but it
can give itself up for the white Bishop
it will happily give itself up just so
the Black Knight can Retreat and escape
and suddenly if we do a quick count it's
level material white has a rook but in
return black has a bishop and two pawns
but more importantly white king is a bit
of a Target there's enough pieces left
for that to be true and also White's
Pawn structure is just ruined forever
so I think this would actually pass the
advantage to Prague and uh the third
alternative by process of elimination
might be the correct one of anchor uh in
this position if we go back rather than
defending this bishop or moving it maybe
you just have to bite the bullet and say
okay I'm going to take your knight uh
you take my Bishop but the one positive
I can see to this is that at least you
get the open file White's Rook now can
uh kind of take over from the line the
BlackRock has evacuated and there's a
threat of Checkmate on the back rank
yeah and also the Rook is trapped yeah
Black's Rook is also without too many
Escape squares the one downside is
you've given up the bishop pair and
White's Pawn structure here it's very
ugly doubled pawns isolated pawns almost
but uh at least you get the open file
and active player so Wesley I think
after a long thing might well go for
this idea pressure is on for a pregnant
under in must win in game four both of
these players sitting in San Francisco
Where We Are we all have reporter Tanya
what's happening in Tanya right now
you got guests with us discussing
exactly what you are all are talking
about Prague can he make a comeback in
this match and I've got another chess
Enthusiast here with me his name is Dan
he's from the Bay Area involved with a
lot of initiatives here uh Dan welcome
to the show thank you for having me
great to be here what's it like to be
here and witness the finals are you
having a good time exciting these
players are the best in the world and
it's fantastic to have this event in my
hometown San Francisco
and who are you rooting for here is I'm
running for that gentleman uh the World
Champ uh Magnus so is it also nice to
see Wesley here in the finals making his
decade I like Wesley a fellow American
like I am so uh Wesley's a great player
too uh I hope he does well maybe uh made
up he wins I'd be happy for him
Wednesdays too so awesome Don it's been
so much fun seeing all the chess
activities going around in the Bay Area
tell us a little bit is the community
super excited about having this final
and all the chess stuff that's on oh
most definitely I know um I give
lectures at the Bernal Heights chess
club and um I can tell you that was all
the buzz uh this past weekend and uh
about wanting to go to the Press event
um having this event here I think just
uh draws more attention to chess and
makes chess uh even more interesting no
it's already interesting but more you
know more uh vibrant uh thing to see uh
more vibrant thing to play particularly
I couldn't agree more with you and one
of the big things about the tour has
been seeing this standout performance by
the young talents across the world what
is it like in San Francisco are a lot of
kids involved with chess a lot of kids
are involved I think Prague uh the the
uh GM Familia you know it really does
inspire a lot of great uh a lot of great
young Talent we have uh but we yeah we
have talent uh young talent that really
aspires to be like these guys one day so
thank you so much Don for joining us
Prague continues to inspire a lot of
youngsters right now he needs to play
some inspiring chess to be back in this
match definitely Tanya thank you for
that report from San Francisco what a
place to be if you love chess
and right now it's a drama for Prague
can he make a comeback can he win this
game
I think it's the first critical moment
of the game at least
of course if he's up against the
computer as we see on the bar white is
doing well but uh Prague has at least
asked Wesley a very very difficult
question and just before that interview
with Dan and Tanya we went through some
of the options for white I think that's
exactly what is going through Wesley's
Soul's head right now he's calculating
three or four different options save the
white dot Square Bishop Retreat the
white dark Square Bishop protect it or
ignore it and take the Black Knight but
that's three or four options and uh
that's why he spent six and a half
minutes none of those options actually
leads to completely sterile equality
none leads to a full straw and maybe
that's frustrating for Wesley uh what do
you think Ivanka yeah thank you I have
to say I agree with you this is a very
important moment for Wesley and he's
running through all those lines that we
mentioned and I think he's going to come
to the conclusion that pawn takes taking
the Knight is the best one it looks the
most solid out of all the other options
you mentioned yeah I agree I think that
Black Knight has lived too long already
and before it gets active again before
it starts munching on some pawns just
remove it from the board
it just I think you do have to break
down some kind of stereotypes in your
head in order to play this move Pawn
takes Knight because you do give up the
bishop pair you do kind of Saddle
yourself with this poor structure long
term but dynamically it still looks
great for white Black's got two pieces
that are still asleep The Rook in the
corner the light Square bishop and after
a long long think he does play the best
move we've seen throughout the tour
there's a phenomenon of making a blunder
after a long thing but not Wesley so he
uh he did pause at the critical moment
sensitivity to that is essential and now
we're expecting White's rook in the
corner to swing the D file has been
vacated why not threaten Checkmate in
one move yeah that is one move
it's Wesley though so I'm gonna also and
also because it's Prague and I've
learned a lesson I'm going to run
through those options as well just to
see whether there's anything else any
other aggressive moves to be played
yeah I mean I guess what could take a
timeout Black's Rook is attacking a
couple of Pawns attacking the F Pawn
especially white could just defend that
with his Bishop but that would give
black the luxury to start developing his
sleeping pieces so it does feel like
this is the most logical move not only
do you threaten Checkmate Rook d8 now up
to the top of the board traps the black
king but you stop black light Square
Bishop from developing
yeah I agree and uh it's very
uncomfortable for pregnant under
especially if that when that Rook will
go to the eighth row I mean how is he
going to develop his uh pieces there on
the left side and also I have to say the
thing that bothers me the most about
Black's position is The Rook sitting on
the F4 Square it feels like it's trapped
it doesn't have too many squares it's uh
going to capture the pawn on F3 but
that's it if you manage somehow this is
this is like I need some like a magic
wand or something if I could pick up
that Bishop sitting on F1 if I could go
and put it on e4
mission accomplished you know I've got
that uh Rook caged
and then now you can come and win it
exactly kick it off at will anytime you
want you can trap it with the Knight you
can even start trapping it with the King
uh this Rook so yeah this is definitely
in the air and right now Prague has a
bigger threat to deal with of course uh
this back rank uh check so there's only
two ways I see of dealing with that
either you have to retreat with your
Bishop as we just showed there cover the
square but then the bishop is a bit
offside temporarily doesn't look too
impressive you still can't solve the
problem of this bishop ever moving uh
that's going to take an eternity uh the
second alternative is to swing across
with the Rook before it gets trapped but
uh maybe the downside to this one is
that after white captures uh there are
maybe other options but after a trade
here suddenly you have another weakness
suddenly this Pawn is
most likely doomed long term and uh yeah
this one doesn't look too great either
yeah and I have to say White's double
pawns they're not that bad because they
can move forward they have that
potential just to advance yeah at some
point you connect your pawns and you
breathe the sight of relief so yeah in
this position it does feel
I mean it feels just too much to allow
this rook in for example you could
create some breathing space for the
black king an escape square but after
this check you're just pinned along this
line uh for quite a long time
and uh again there's ideas of White's
night coming in and the White's night's
stepping in some ideas of Checkmate the
hook mate that is the hook mate yeah
this is I mean this is one checkmating
idea there's another checkmating idea of
course where the Rook takes born and
different type of bookmate both white
Rooks are threatening to catch this
black king so yeah surely you can't
allow that to happen and he does indeed
try prevent the main threat Bishop
dropping back covering the vital d8
Square
now it's up to Wesley can he get away
with trying to re-maneuver his Bishop to
trap this black Rook and uh okay first
he uses this Rook to defend this pawn
and maybe he's got that idea in mind
Ivanka uh for example if black takes the
time out and I don't even know what
black does if black just pushes a pawn
for example the bishop might indeed try
to step into the middle of the board to
cage this Intruder yeah it is looking
very good for white we've got to say uh
long term black is okay but short term
too many problems weak back rank trapped
rook and two pieces that are fast asleep
on the queen side
and in fact there's an immediate threat
of The Rook
getting uh cat trapped the night is
actually going to go backwards
yeah uh if the bishop does step forward
yeah the Knight is going to come
backwards and trap this Rook
um yeah the Knight is going to come for
it at some point in the near future
big problems for Prague on the clock
he's okay but on the board Wesley's in
full control oh and he thought the only
one and it must win the situation here
Prague there is actually three players
in must win situations uh here on day
four game fours Mama Dr of he has to win
game four again sorry guys you to take
that one to tie breaks and Duda who
before today was on top of the table
with Magnus Carlsen he has to win
against Liam Lair and taking a look at
the bars in those ones
slightly over to Liam's side and
definitely over to ergai Seaside it's
the hopes of tie breaks getting Slimmer
it does look that way and actually I
just took a look at Eric icy's game he
can win on the spot oh if he finds one
move if he doesn't then manager is right
back in that game so it's actually a
critical moment Eric icy is the type of
advantage that either he can just end
things immediately and win or manager of
has a Fighting Chance
so it's uh oh my major I think he
spotted it he's probably seen Eric icy's
winning move Eric icy is still thinking
I'm just looking over at that one it's a
critical moment there meanwhile Prague
has pushed upon this is what we expected
giving the black king some breathing
space but Mama jarov suffering down the
camera he's had a tough day Eric I see
he's suddenly come to life in this
tournament and if he's watching the
webcams right now he might realize that
he does have that one move yeah it
doesn't look like he's watching the
webcam and he hasn't spotted it yet it's
the type of move if you see it you play
it and you win the game immediately but
uh I don't think he spotted it yet I
really see he didn't find The Knockout
blow
uh he's still winning but not as winning
as earlier so we will see the evaluation
bar in that game between Eric icy and
manager go down slightly he didn't find
the knockout
that Majora have given a second life oh
he has to win it Mom and Daryl but one
match is finished Magnus Crossing
winning all three games against Anish
giri to take that match win and let's
hear what denish giri said after losing
that match
and you should tough match for you but
it felt like you got good positions out
of the opening but then something went
wrong very soon what happened there
yeah I think today was a very important
day for me and uh
I think
you could tell it's a bad day but uh
you know like let's say your car is
making a lot of noise and then
you don't know what's going on you bring
it to like different
to different uh car dealers and you're
asking what's up and then finally you
bring it to a dealer and then he tells
you you know like an engine is broken
and you think okay it's a bad day but
it's not really the bad day yeah it's
maybe the good day because you finally
discovered what's the issue so then
you're probably gonna fix the engine and
everything's gonna be fine so I think
today was the the day that
I found out the
Sports broken what is broken
I mean
um
honestly I at some point I was thinking
that maybe Magnus is uh because my
results were not so good against him my
result that maybe he's just Superior
player
um but today I I realized there is
definitely more to it than uh than him
being a Spirit player uh I think it was
useful for me and I hope I'm sure next
time I'll play better because uh I think
it's not possible to play worse
it's very nice to see you take the
positives from this I want to ask you in
that third last game it felt like you
got your chances out of the opening and
had a better position there was this one
moment where you can capture an E5 with
the rook in the pawn and this is
something we were just talking about why
did you make the decision it was like it
was really funny so I was about to like
remove rookie five and then I thought to
myself like you know if I were a noob I
could consider taking with a pawn as
well
but obviously any normal person takes to
under only five bedroom immediately and
then
somehow like generally like my whole
thinking process today like throughout
the games it was just so messed up like
it's I've never had that like normally I
think something during the games and
okay I miss certain things but today
like it was really like something
really special I have to say I mean it's
really remarkable it's like also uh I I
knew up front the moves I was making
were bad and it's it sounds like a weird
thing but it's
it usually doesn't happen to me but it
really did also the in the other game I
could play Knight C4 then I played King
of f8 and when I play King f8 I'm 100
sure this is a very bad move
but I don't know why I'm making it and
the same with this I mean I I literally
paused thinking that a weaker player
than me would pause here to consider
different captures but a player like me
will take the Rook instantly and then I
take with the phone it's really like
next level I mean okay I went very deep
with my thinking but it's just so messed
up uh like I I don't know like I'm going
like instead of making a move that comes
to mind I'm going like meta and it's
really backfiring do you think it's
something to do with playing a player
like Magnus that has this effect
yeah of course it's
um it's something within me and not
within my opponent but um that said I'm
um yeah I think um I'm looking forward
to my upcoming games yeah so are we good
luck thanks Anish
you manages to still be uh funny and
give some good answers Amish after even
after that very disappointing match loss
against
Magnus
he moves here yeah a few moves here the
Black Brook has escaped from its jail
just in time to trade off but Wesley
he's trying to kill the fun for Prague
he's just swapping off pieces he's just
gonna plant his white knight into a good
Square soon and uh yeah still prag on
the defensive I just want to say as well
before we move on from guru's interview
that is great that's really instructive
for everyone I love what Anish said
there he's going to learn from this and
move on and we all lose games we all
lose I mean even the top players they've
lost hundreds in their life but they
need they just learn from every single
one
and he maybe did some overthinking there
and maybe next time he'll trust his
instincts more his results might be
better because of that and today's
experience will stand him in good stead
yeah so it's not always about the
results
of course results help but it's about
learning and meanwhile we do see white
tonight enter a good Square Ivanka yeah
and Wesley knows exactly what he has to
do and it's all about just putting his
pieces on great uh posts the bishop is
also going to relocate itself to the
center why it's F pawns are going to
start advancing and Wesley has a very
solid position and it's not just solid
it's also quite good because he also has
a Target the D4 born on D4 is just a
Sitting Duck yeah and earlier we talked
about the potency of the two Bishops and
how incredible they can be if they break
the position open and if they can find
active lines but look at these poor
pieces right now uh white white has just
completely blocked the center this dark
Square Bishop's staring at its own Pawn
how depressing is that you can never
break out onto a nice diagonal this
other Bishop I was going to say is a bad
piece and the only way it can come to
life is to sit on the Square it does
defend the B7 Pawn but as soon as that
happens Wesley says no I'm going to swap
off one of your Bishops and that is the
key to playing against the two Bishops a
knight versus Bishop it's never clear
whose piece is better but uh yeah Bishop
pear together are strong so eliminate
your opponent's Bishop pair trade off
one of those Bishops and you will be
much happier this just looks fantastic
as you said uh Ivanka for example if the
bishops get traded off you can even take
with the pawn next move if you just
plant your king in the center blockade
this uh this you call it a Sitting Duck
Right a sitting Target in the center and
if you can blockade this Pawn that means
the black Bishop is bad forever for
eternity and not just that but white is
threatening this guy this is a backward
weakness as well White's Rook can come
across and attack it soon
riddled full of holes Black's position
yeah
and unfortunately you know Prague
probably would be dreaming of a draw but
a draw is insufficient he's in a
must-win situation so this means that he
has to gamble
he gambles already by bringing his Rook
across he's hoping that white gets
greedy I was going to say Wesley's
definitely not going to get greedy but
if White had captured this Pawn Sonny
Black can start pushing his Pawn forward
that's the dream but nope Wesley shuts
the door the king is a great blockader
in end games it's never going to get
kicked away black has no Knights to ever
check this King away and uh yeah this
Pawn is the target next move White's
night is glorious and uh Prague tries to
undermine it tries to remove the
defender of that white knight
the sad thing is white can just support
his Pawn if he wants to this is
something you've been wanting to do for
a while your Banker maybe you don't even
need to you could also make an argument
for taking this Pawn
every option just looks very strong for
white right now if you want to play with
no risk just push this Pawn forward
support your fellow in the Santa
not looking good for brag then
it's a Master Class by Wesley I mean I
feel bad for questioning his ability to
contain prague's energy but he's done
that really well he's swapped the Queens
off early he's stabilized in an end game
and he's just playing purely on strategy
and okay rather than go for the safe
option he takes this Pawn he's still
pretty safe I think this is pretty safe
and I I knew that Wesley would do it
because his opposite colored Bishops as
well and as long as he maintains control
on the light squares there's no way that
prags rook and Bishop are able to
combine to break down White's defense is
yeah look at the pawn structure in a
moment as well black has no past pawns
these pawns are so well blockaded in the
center for example white can just come
back and sit in the middle and how with
opposite color Bishops are you ever
going to break this blockade
the question is I mean it's an
impossible question you're just never
going to break that blockade if anything
white is better white can push on this
side of the board or it can Target your
weaknesses in the middle that's I think
that's the key to the position you know
why it should just be ambitious here
yeah and sit forever okay prank doesn't
go up to the color Bishops he needs to
win and that would have been uh
tantamount to giving up his chances so
he removes the Bishops instead but after
this Rook move he is attacking the
Knight there's two ways for Wesley to
deal with this either you can just
Retreat the Knight or what he's done
step forward to the pawn he's just
swapping off all the pieces cynical but
effective he's giving pregnant and a
taste of his own medicine um
counter-attack is the key and
he has to take that night yep but look
how everything's just disappearing from
the board
um if you take this Pawn now as black
then white is happily going to capture
this Pawn at this point it's just
trading everything off and white is
going to emerge at least one Pawn up
actually so still Prague on the
defensive and it's one side of traffic
they're playing for two results now it's
either a win for white or a draw price
need for a win it's almost disappeared
now oh it's looking good for Wesley to
win the match Arjun Arrow guy C has now
won the match against muhammadiro to
gain his first three points in the tour
finals winning two games today Arjun
very impressive stuff by the young
Indians sitting in the middle of the
night in India
so our only hope now probably for tie
breaks if frag isn't up to something
extremely genius right now is if Duda
wins the game against Liam
is the bar slightly over to Liam's side
yeah it's very complicated that game
though okay let's still go either way
between Duda and Liam it depends on
Liam's nerves as well I think dude has
just kept the tension that's what the
other two were unable to do mamajarov
and Prague in the muscle in situations
you need to keep tension as many pieces
on the board as possible and dude has
done that but the other two haven't
so Prague yeah this is far from a tense
position unfortunately White's Rook is
now just going to go and capture some
pawns and you can tell on practice body
language he doesn't really believe
anymore
um it's uh it's too far gone especially
against a great endgame player like
Wesley
I agree and you know what they say all
Rick endings are drawn
and here actually in fact Wesley is
probably winning but uh yeah Prague
impossible task
yeah an impossible task he looks down I
was going to wonder whether Wesley
offered another draw maybe or
maybe Prague was checking whether that
was allowed but no uh Wesley doesn't
even need to offer a draw in this
position because there's zero risk for
white
yeah hoovered all the pieces off the
board if we do a quick count it's
currently six Pawns
against six but everything is
disappearing look at this White's Rook
getting active blackstruck trying to get
active but white has a bunch of Pawns
you could capture right now
I think White's Rook will just step up
one square and take a pawn
actually I think Wesley's two pawns on
the left side are going to start running
and white should be winning actually
objectively
yeah and uh I think Wesley will go for
the win why not
um the great thing about this position
for Wesley is it is quite
straightforward and also he can draw on
patterns that he's seen many many times
for like instinct instinctively you know
that okay once you capture and eliminate
the B Pawn then white pawns they're just
so fast they can just wriggle up the
board almost by themselves and Prague
has to do all sorts of Houdini acts with
his Rook and the problem as well is that
white is playing with two pieces we talk
about activity in end games white has an
active rook and an active King black
might have an active Rook but look at
the black king what is it doing it's
just not participating and white is
playing with two pieces black with one
therefore it's entirely logical that
white is winning this game and uh okay
black now is down the pawn he had to
push this one before it was captured if
Wesley wants to be really cynical he
could just take a pawn with the white
King right now maybe the white Rook will
go hunting down this black people
plus 4.4 the computer confirms white is
winning but uh Wesley doesn't even need
to look for wins
and the bar has shut off for the emblem
as well and that must win game for Duda
is he taking risks and I won't do enough
to just taking massive risks he's just
sacrificed a knight uh Liam's King is
very very open in that one so still not
out of danger for the Vietnamese player
but Liam he's just the Kryptonite right
he's just you called it before the show
even today Ivanka he's just found a way
to play against Duda I think all of
duda's opponents need to go and study
what Liam is doing against him it seems
to be really effective he could have won
the match already today uh dude uh sorry
Liam against Duda if he'd wanted to I
mean he's already due to escape a couple
of times he's been dominant and didn't
Liam also ruin the front for Magnus in
the Oslo Esports
you did beat Magnus there as well yeah
and they face each other tomorrow
Liam okay and coming for the Top Guns
here yeah he certainly is and someone
who is clinically shutting down all of
pragnananda's hopes is that Wesley just
look at it there's no chance now and
there we see Liam Le in his office
getting ready to defend a one position
against Duda yep that's all he needs to
do defend at the end because he is a
whole night ahead in that game and you
can tell on dude is body language he
doesn't really think he can save it turn
it around anymore meanwhile in this game
uh between Wesley and Prague it is over
we do see a draw and Wesley takes the
match I'm a friendly handshake between
the two
a draw means Wesley so when's the match
to take all three points he is really
waking up now in the tour this is his
debut this season Wesley